foreign
comes from Tommy in California in 2009
my mom took out a parent plus loan for
me to go to college I also took out
seventy thousand dollars of student
loans she never made a payment towards
them in her mind it was it was my loan
under her name that I should pick up
whatever I'm financially stable because
my mom never paid she now owes a hundred
thousand dollars and is begging me to
take it back under my name I just got a
new job where I make a hundred and forty
three thousand dollars it's a huge jump
from 30 to 40 000 I've made for several
years and I can finally make a dent in
my own loans she asks me every week or
so when are you taking your student
loans back ouch
my mom is a nurse practitioner
practitioner but often complains that
she is broke she is currently paying off
two luxury cars that she bought within
24 hours of each other one for work one
for church
okay who has a church car a luxury
church I had a church car
so great
loans that she borrowed from her 401k to
purchase land and other credit cards she
says that her own student loans are such
a burden that she had to stop paying her
life insurance to afford the payments
should I take the hundred thousand
dollars back under my name since she
feels like she was tricked into getting
them whoo
there is a lot your mom is a freaking
Head Case oh oh my God
man that that's there's a lot of sticky
stuff you're a child and I'm an adult
and I take that alone in my name for you
to go to college but I got tricked
and I'm still being irresponsible with
my money
so has this woman ever done anything
wrong in her own eyes she has a church
car for God's sakes I'm going home and
telling Sharon I need another car I
don't have a church car I need another
car I knew that I knew I needed a car I
just didn't know what it was for it's
for church
geez what in the world that's weird oh
man and so much guilt and shame in that
yeah so here's the thing if you promised
your mom when you were a child
that if she took out these Parent Plus
Loans that you would pay them and you
and you pinky swear it's a bit shake at
the kitchen table when you're 18 years
old and you told her you would cover
them then you should cover them but the
story I just read or that Christina just
read doesn't say that
it sounds like your mom did this she was
trying to help she did a stupid thing
trying to do a good thing and she's done
a lot of stupid things in her life you
listed a whole bunch of them here and um
and and now she wants to dump it on you
so here's what I would do
um
number one under no circumstances do you
take it back under your name okay
uh number two if you choose to help her
with it you can help her by throwing
grenades over the fence throwing money
over the fence but we're not going to
move the loan over into your name okay
besides that I'm not even positive you
can pull that off with a parent plus
loan I think it's pretty well stuck in
her name and you're not qualified so
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to get your stuff paid off so no
you can't help her until you're debt
free
then if you choose to help her at that
point
here's how the conversation would be if
it was me you can do whatever you want
to do but it would be mom
you are really ridiculously done with
money
I am willing to help you with you taking
out this loan because it was for my
benefit
um but I'm not willing to do it all and
I'm not willing to do it while you're
paying two car payments including a
church car
just shoot me I mean that's just stupid
straight up stupid and a nurse
practitioner should be making a pile of
money in California you should be able
to work your way through a lot of this
stuff so we're gonna get rid of a bunch
of cars I'm going to help you do that
I'm going to be your biggest cheerleader
you're going to get on a budget you're
going to go through Financial Peace
University and then every thousand
dollars you pay on that old Parent PLUS
Loan I'll put a thousand dollars on it
oh I like that if you pay nothing on it
and you continue to stay out of control
I'm gonna match that
nothing
that's exactly I'm gonna put on exactly
what you put on and I'm going to help
you get this out of control under
control get your life back coach you
through a complete transformation
because darling you need one
but you know this idea that somehow she
is a victim she's a victim of her own
stupidity like all of us are when I went
bankrupt you know whose fault it was
Dave's
it wasn't Ronald Reagan's
he was the president
it wasn't Jimmy Carter's he was the
President right before that and both of
them did some really stupid stuff but
neither one of them calls me to go
bankrupt it was Dave's fault
and it wasn't my dad's fault it wasn't
my mom's fault and it wasn't my dog's
fault it was my fault so part of part of
straightening up your dad gum life is
taking responsibility for it yeah and I
think this just also highlights what I
think I've heard Rachel say where it's
like a lot of the student loan crisis is
a parenting crisis it's parents letting
their kids go into debt but if you're a
parent who takes out a Parent PLUS Loan
and then expects your kid to pay it off
that's that's a lot that's rough well I
mean some parents do that and the kid
says okay I'll promise then you made the
promise I'll stick you to your promise
then but he didn't do that but even even
if your kid says I promise that 18 years
old that is still a kid I barely an
adult promising to pay that back like as
a parent you should stop and say are you
really willing to make that promise do
you understand what that promise means
in the long run because that's a heavy
promise to make it 18 years old it's
like one of your parents co-signing for
a 16 year old to get a BMW you're an
idiot
you're an idiot you deserve the problems
that are coming your way you just signed
up for stupid on steroids